meet John a software developer John
develops a program and now he realizes
the program is surrounded by a lot of
bugs
John starts exploring a solution
he surfs through the internet checks
programmer communities
doubting every step of the way John
fills his problem is not solved
desperate to find the solution John
meets his friend Adam
comes up with an idea of an artificially
intelligent and practical solution
called the chat GPT
Adam says chat GPT has the caliber to
systematically resolve all the bugs with
an elaborate explanation for every step
it makes chat GPT is an AI trained model
that works in a conversational way
developed by open AI
fascinated by hearing this John asks
Adam to explain him in detail after Adam
explains that GPT AKA degenerative
retraining Transformer has come a long
way
before the introduction of GPT natural
language processing used to deal with a
specific task with large amounts of data
GPT was first released in 2018 which
contained 117 million parameters
T gpt2 and gpt3 each one is stronger
than the one before
the main reason why GPT received little
attention was that it was more of an
idea or task than a finished product
but after the introduction of gpt2 it
gained a lot of attention as it could
accurately predict the word that would
begin a text then they introduced gpt3
which is a strong language model
achieving translation question answering
and Performing three-digit arithmetic
[Music]
all compared to all other achievements
of open AI so how does it work chat gbt
uses deep learning techniques to
generate human-like text it is based on
the machine learning model derived from
the class called the large language
model
chat GPT is a byproduct of instruct GPT
instruct GPT introduced a strategy for
integrating human feedback into the
training process to match model outputs
this Innovative technology made chat GPT
exceptional
it is trained on the massive data sets
of text from the internet and learns
from the patterns and relationships
between words and phrases a response to
a prompt by determining the next word
based on the context then repeats the
process until a stop condition is met
as a result chat GPT can produce various
logical responses to various queries and
prompts the most important components of
chat GPT are the Transformer model and
language model coming to the Transformer
model it is a neural network
architecture designed to process
sequential data
consists of multiple layers of
self-attention and a feed forward
Network
after the Transformer model has
processed the input a decoder generates
the output
the decoder uses the context provided by
the encoder to generate the response
the model is trained using unsupervised
learning and fine-tune on specific tasks
using supervised learning
for successful completion of tasks it
needs pre-trained data the model first
encodes the input text then converts it
to a numerical representation which can
be processed by the model's neural
network
this encoding is done using the embedded
layer that Maps the work
then comes the language model
chat GPT is trained as a language model
trained to predict the next word in a
sequence given the previous words
the language model intends to produce
rational consistent and meaningful
output
the pre-trained chat GPT can be tuned
for a specific task
so chatgpt passes a fine tuning test by
answering questions generating text
summaries or generating text in response
to a query
for all chat GPT is a powerful language
model with a combination of techniques
like deep learning machine learning
neural networks and natural language
processing
can chat GPT change a wide variety of
business tasks John asked chat GPT
possesses the ability to automate
content creation on social media create
chatbot and e-commerce sites provide
medical assistance by acting as a
symptom checker write code and assist a
developer thus chat GPT can change the
working of every industry now John can
resolve any coding issue without looking
into any other resources
but like any other technology chatgpt
comes with a few limitations that can be
its Achilles heel
chat GPT is capable of developing
content up to 2021
it finds difficulty in providing logical
reasoning in certain situations and also
chat GPT lags in Translation
summarization and sometimes question
answering but above all chat GPT has
shown remarkable ability by providing
accurate answers flawlessly in a
creative way in very short periods of
time
but before we end I have a question for
you which language model does chat GPT
belong to
1. ppt3
2. GPT 4
3. gpt2
four GPT
give the answer with reasoning and stand
a chance to win an Amazon voucher think
about it and leave the answer in the
comments section and we will provide the
answer in the next week we hope you
enjoyed this video if you did a thumbs
up would be really appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on the Bell icon for
more on the latest Technologies and
Trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from Simply learn
[Music]